so the word Adam means uncuttable that's
right so the Greeks we're thinking of it
as a tiny hard sphere that's right and
even up into the 1800s
that was the idea of an atom the
smallest piece of matter tiny hard
sphere yep yep but then we find out that
that's not quite right not quite there
are experiments in the 1800s that
discovered the electron JJ Thompson's
experiments really worked out the
electron was smaller than an atom
smaller than the about a thousand times
smaller than the hydrogen atom and it
was in it all atoms that's right not
just hydrogen whatever material he did
his experiments on he found their
electrons in them there are electrons in
all atoms so I guess when you find
something that's smaller than an atom
you need to propose a new model for the
atom that actually has something smaller
in it some substructure that's right so
you know something like this this is our
model of the atom this is our model of
it in his day was known as the plum
pudding model but here we have cherry
tart cherry tart okay so but the idea
being that we have an overall atom
usually pictured a spherical rather than
2d but but embedded within it this is
the important part there are negative
electrons represented by cherries and
they can come it out the overall atom is
neutral so that means the pudding part
must be positive now how would you get
one of these electrons out of our
pudding here so electrons are negatively
charged so we'll need to put something
very positive which attracts electrons
at a high voltage and that would have
the effect of say like plucking a
chariot out of the pudding that's pretty
much it
yep I you could do it kind of like that
so we're simulating hmm what it would be
like to put a positive charge on here
that's right that's right pulling the
electrons out of the enim hmm wow that's
quite a delicious yeah that's how it's
delicious model of the atom I've got to
say yeah so should we say we split the
atom why don't you go ahead yeah you
want me to hurt you yes okay I know what
could happen a whole bunch of anyone
could be really yeah yeah that's right
ready 1 2 3